Now there are two main features of RNA
that distinguish it from DNA. The first is
that RNA uses a different nitrogenous base attached
to its nucleotides called Uracil or U instead
of Thymine, T. The second distinguishing feature is
that RNA is typically single-stranded. Unlike DNA which
you normally see two strands in a helix
together with each other. But even though it's single
stranded, it's still composed of nitrogenous bases, just like the DNA,
dioxynucleitides are. So this means that RNA also has the ability to base pair.
In this case, uracil behaves in RNA like thiamine behaves in DNA.
And so uracil binds with adenine the same way thiamine would bind with adenine.
So hopefully you'll notice that based on the chemistry
alone, RNA and DNA are very similar. And there
are just a few differences that distinguish them. Chemically
speaking, these differences are very important. And again out of
the scope of this course, you may find out
later exactly why DNA and RNA are so different,
and why their functions can vary so much. I
want you to see if you can tell me which
one of the following images. Do think best
represents RNA as it is most likely found in
the cell. Do you think you'd see a single
strand of RNA, just as a straight, linear strand,
all laid out like this first option. Or
do you think you would see something that looks
like this, where the single strand has folded back
on itself, where it appears there may be some
Base pairing. Whichever answer you end up picking, I'd
like for you to try and justify your answer
in the text box here, explaining why you think
the RNA would look like that inside a cell.